- [Instructor] So where we
left off in the last video,
we had Alexander the Great
consolidating his power
over the Macedonian Empire.
And in particular, he puts
down a rebellion in Thebes,
destroys the city,
which makes the other
city-states of Greece say,
hey, we're not gonna mess
with this person anymore.
And then Alexander says,
I am now going to conquer Asia.
I am now going to conquer
the Persian Empire,
do what my father wanted
to do before he died.
And so he puts one of
his father's generals,
now one of his generals, in
charge of Greece, Antipater.
Antipater, declares him regent,
and then leads troops off
to what many people say
is have the greatest,
or many historians call,
the greatest adventure of all time.
His attempt to conquer the Persian Empire
and become the king of Asia.
So the year is 334 BCE,
and the first major battle that Alexander
and his army encounters
is at the Granicus River,
here in modern-day Turkey.
Now, keep in mind that Alexander's force,
depending on what time we're looking at,
it numbers between 40 and 50,000 troops,
a good number of them
infantry, some cavalry.
And most of the battles
that we'll see him fight,
especially the next two
against the Persian forces,
he's hugely outnumbered.
But at Granicus, he
actually has an advantage
in terms of the number of infantry he has.
He's slightly outnumbered
in terms of cavalry,
but he's able to defeat
the Persian forces.
Now these Persian forces,
they are significant.
They're led by the Persian satraps,
these are the governors
of the territories,
I guess you could say.
The Persian regions or provinces
in this area in Asia Minor.
And he's able to defeat them.
But as important as Granicus is,
he still, Alexander still
has not come directly
against Darius III.
Darius III is the Shah in
Shah, the King of Kings,
the king of Persia.
And not to confuse Darius
III with the Darius
who 150 years before this attacked Greece.
So now you have Alexander,
his first decisive victory
against the Persians.
He makes his way down the Anatolian coast,
in his mind liberating
many of these cities
that used to be Greek cities.
Now if we zoom in a little bit,
you can see the way this map is set up.
Let me zoom in a little bit.
Where you see these dotted
lines around a city,
this means that Alexander's
forces siege the city.
They surrounded it, they
didn't let anything go
in or out until the city surrendered.
And so you see this path of
Alexander and his forces.
We then go into 333 BCE.
Outside of the forward movement
of Alexander and his troops
and their ability to take
over all of Asia Minor,
modern-day Turkey in only
a matter of a little more
than a year,
what also happens in 333 BCE,
since some of you might
have been wondering
well, what ever happens to Sparta?
Philip of Macedon never took over Sparta.
Do they stay independent forever?
And the simple answer is no.
In 333 BCE, Antipater defeats the Spartans
at the battle of
Megalopolis and forces them
into what we now call
the League of Corinth.
So let's keep now going
back to where Alexander is.
So Antipater clearly was competent at
maintaining power in Greece.
And the next major battle that Alexander
and his troops face is at Issus.
And what makes Issus significant is that
they are hugely outnumbered.
Historians disagree by how
much they're outnumbered.
Remember, we said Alexander's
forces were around
40 or 50,0000,
while the Persians at Issus,
depending on which account you look at,
were at least 150,000,
probably over 100,000.
More ancient accounts talk
about many hundreds of thousands
or even a million troops.
What also made Issus
significant is this is where,
this is the first time that Darius III,
the Shah in Shah, the king of Persia,
directly confronts Alexander.
Well, Alexander once again is able to,
or at least here is able
to overcome unlikely odds
and defeat the Persian army,
sending Darius into retreat.
And he retreats so fast,
he even leaves an
encampment where his mother,
his wife, and his two daughters are there.
And Alexander then takes them captive,
but treats them very
nicely and then eventually
marries one of the daughters.
So after that defeat,
Darius is on the retreat,
or after that defeat for Darius,
this victory for Alexander,
Alexander then goes on into the Lavant,
modern-day Syria and Lebanon
and Israel and Palestine.
And you can see he takes
siege of the cities
of Tyre and Gaza,
but by the time he gets through that,
it's now 332 and he
makes his way into Egypt,
and he's relatively unopposed.
The satraps in Egypt to
say, okay, you know what?
We recognize you.
They treat him as a liberator,
and he even takes a
pretty large detour to go
to the Oracle for the god Ammon,
and there he is reassured
that he is a son of Ammon.
And he already is told
by his mother Olympius
that he is the son of Zeus,
and so many people call Alexander,
or he calls himself now,
Alexander Zeus Ammon,
the son of Zeus Ammon.
So once again he's trying
to really make himself,
or maybe he believes himself,
that he is half god,
that he is a demi-god.
But then he continues on with this,
I guess you could say grand adventure,
and I don't want to
romanticize it too much
because even though he is in some way
conquering and/or unifying
these large areas,
there's also a lot of bloodshed,
a lot of civilians dying.
This is a very ugly thing
that only looks romantic
from maybe a distance of
many thousands of years.
But when you think about it,
it would not have been
very pleasant to have lived
in any of these cities that
Alexander and his troops
are going through.
But then he leaves Egypt,
and the whole time after
the defeat of Issus,
Darius keeps sending him treaties
to say hey, maybe we
can work this thing out.
Maybe you can just stop to
the west of the Euphrates.
I'll give you this or that.
But Alexander keeps
saying nope, not for me.
I want to be the king of Asia.
There's only one king of Asia.
And so they eventually
meet again at Gaugamela.
Once again, a very
significant battle in history
where once again Darius is there
and has a significant force
advantage over Alexander,
and this time doesn't make the mistake
of meeting him in a relatively narrow area
where his force advantage
won't really be an advantage.
But even at Gaugamela,
Alexander is able to
decisively defeat him.
And Darius has to flee over
the mountains to Ecbatana.
My apologies, 'cause I
know I'm probably not
pronouncing it perfectly.
And Alexander and his forces then go on
to capture Babylon and Susia,
and Susia was actually one of the capitals
of the Achaemenid Empire.
So this whole way they're able
to get all of this treasure
and start sending it back to Greece.
And then, we eventually get to,
and by this point having
been defeated at Issus
and now Gaugamela and being on the run,
the Persian Empire is, you
could say it's already fallen,
or it's definitely falling,
but it becomes really official once we get
to 330 BCE.
And remember, this is less than five years
since Alexander started,
and that's short by any time frame.
But they're on foot and on horseback.
This is not modern warfare where they have
tanks and trucks and planes.
And the facts are
conquered so much territory
and empires over 200
years old in this short
about of time frame is
kind of breathtaking.
But it's in 330 where the forces go to
the Achaemenid capital of Persepolis,
the capital for over 200 years,
and they sack that town.
And not only do they sack that town,
they destroy the town.
And I'll repeat it again,
Alexander the Great,
he's romanticized a lot,
he's called the Great,
but they destroy that town in a way that
you would not make your parent's proud.
Let's just put it that way.
But at that point he is now
king of the Persian Empire.
Darius is officially on the run.
And what Alexander now
cares about is continuing
this adventure, continuing
it east into what
we now consider to be
Afghanistan, Turkemenistan,
Uzbekistan, and modern-day Pakistan.
He also wants to get Darius.
Some would argue he wants
to kill him himself,
some would argue that he wants to somehow
have Darius declare
Alexander as the rightful
Shah in Shah, king of Asia.
And so you can see the path
of Alexander and his forces.
After they destroy Persepolis,
they then go up, they turn northwards.
They go through all of
these cities up here.
Then in 329, they're on,
they're following the trail of Darius.
Darius eventually gets captured and killed
by one of his satraps,
someone by the name of Bessus.
And Bessus, who is one of
the satraps of Bactria,
kills Darius and declares
himself Artaxerxes V.
He wants to be the Shah in Shah.
Well, eventually Alexander
catches up with Bessus in 329.
He's really angry that
Bessus has killed Darius.
He's also likely angry
that Bessus is claiming
that he is the Shah in Shah.
And so he kills Bessus
in fairly brutal form.
And there's different accounts
of how the killing happened,
but all of them are
various degrees of brutal.
But from there Alexander's
troops continued on eastward,
continued on eastward
into what we now consider
to be Afghanistan and Pakistan.
And there he has the famous
battle with the king of Porus
where he encounters
these 200 war elephants.
But once again he's this
great military tactician,
and he's able to defeat the king.
And along this whole way
it's worth mentioning
he sets up all of these towns,
he sets up 20 Alexandrias.
And near here he even
sets up a town named after
his horse Bucephalus,
the town of Bucephala.
And Alexander is eager to keep conquering.
Once he defeats the
king of Porus, he says,
hey, I want to go conquer
the rest of India.
But his troops are far from
home and they are tired
and they are spread thin
and they're getting sick.
They are not so interested in that.
So eventually Alexander says, all right,
I'm with y'all.
Let's go back.
And the troops are really, really happy.
They make their way back.
You can see the path back after,
and you can see as they follow
the Indus River in Pakistan.
And eventually we get to 323 BCE,
and Alexander is back in Babylon.
And it's over there in
Babylon that Alexander dies
at the ripe old age of 32.
It's mindblowing to think
about how much happened
in the 12 years that he was emperor
of the Macedonians or even
the Shah in Shah of Persia.
He was able to defeat an
empire over 200 years old.
And what's significant about this is that
as he conquered,
he encouraged his troops to assimilate.
In fact, he was criticized
for maybe assimilating
a little bit too much.
But he dies in Babylon,
and it's not clear exactly why he dies.
He was a major drinker.
Some people say alcohol poisoning.
Some people say it was direct poisoning.
But needless to say,
this was one of the
most significant decades
in human history, this conquest
of Alexander the Great.